and i've grieved with them
and and in my wallet
i still to this day
carry a sheet of paper with the names of
their loved ones
so that they're never forgotten in
congress
so mr chairman as we have this
conversation you're right you've met
you've met families we've all met the
families
i just want to be clear i'm here today
in part
because alyssa olidef and scott beagle
and martin duque
and nick doret and aaron feis and jamie
guttenberg and chris hixson
and luke hoyer and carol lockford and
gina montalto and joaquin oliver
and elena petty and meadow pollock and
helena ramsey and alex shachter and
carmen chentrap and peter wang
can not be the families are still
grieving
as are the community of sandy hook and
las vegas and too many more to name
there are not words in the english
language to properly describe
how the remarks of miss green makes
these communities
feel they are still suffering they will
suffer
forever and this makes it so much worse
because green has not accepted
responsibility for her actions
spreading these dangerous lies if
anything she seems to be emboldened as
promised that she'll never apologize
she's not apologized for amplifying a
call for that summary execution of the
speaker of the house
when promoting a rally in washington dc
she called for a takeover of the capital
with violence if necessary she said that
congress is
nothing and they should fear us they
should be cowering in fear
she told her followers to flood the
capital flood all of the government
buildings go inside
these are public buildings we own them
now look at where we are one month
removed from a deadly insurrection
what if republican leaders said in
response to these comments as ms green
joined their ranks not enough finally
this week
the senate leader leader mcconnell
decried ms green's
uh what he referred to as loony lies and
conspiracy theories
and he described her as a cancer for the
republican party and the country
but in the house mr speaker mr ranking
member
ms green was rewarded with seats on both
the educational labor committee
and the budget committee republican
leadership isn't holding her account
rated in the united states congress that
is why i support house resolution 72. my
yield back
thank you very much i'm now happy to uh
my friend from indiana the ranking
member of the ethics committee is
wallowski
thank you mr chairman ranking thank you
chairman mcgovern
ranking member cole and members of the
rules committee i appear before the
committee today as the ranking member
of the house ethics committee a position
i was appointed to
just two weeks ago in fact this is the
first time
chairman joyce and i have even seen each
other even virtually
since my appointment this is my second
term
serving on the ethics committee and i
was looking forward to working with
chairman deutsch
in a collegial and bipartisan
manner but here we are
managing a contentious politically
driven resolution
that was assigned to our committee and
will now be on the house floor without
proper consideration by the ethics
committee
what are we doing mr chairman chairman
deutsch
first let me say that many republicans
have denounced statements made by
representative greene
before she became a member of congress
and i do
the same as i appear in front of you
today republican house leadership
said months ago that representative
greene's comments are appalling
and he had no tolerance from then
neither do i and i have a statement on
the record
as well i associate myself with my
leadership statements and i know many of
my colleagues have
and do as well i am not here
to defend representative greene i'm here
to defend the process of the house
and within this house the integrity of
the ethics committee
and the functions of the majority and
minority parties
the committee on ethics is unique the
committee rules
in fact recognize the importance of the
unique way
this committee functions i would like to
read
a directly from the committee rulebook
from the forward on page one the
committee on ethics is unique in the
house
of representatives consistent with the
duty to carry out its advisory and
enforcement responsibilities in an
impartial manner
the committee is the only standing
committee of the house of
representatives the membership
of which is divided evenly by party
these rules are intended to provide a
fair
a fair procedural framework for the
conduct of the committee's activities
to help ensure that the committee serves
well the people
of the united states the house of
representatives and the members
officers and employees of the house of
representatives
the committee works best in the
collegial and bipartisan manner in fact
during the 113th 114th 115th 116
congresses all votes taken in the
investigative subcommittees were
unanimous
the republicans and democrats serving on
these subcommittees were in agreement
all of the work of the committee
completed by its sitting members
the members who are asked to serve in
the investigative subcommittees
and the committee's professional and
nonpartisan staff
all of the work is accomplished
by bipartisan cooperation and the work
of the ethics committee is extensive
in 116th congress alone the committee
commenced or continued investigative
fact gatherings regarding
50 separate investigative matters
impaneled
six investigative subcommittees held 32
invested subcommittee meetings
filed five reports with the house
totaling over 3 300 pages
regarding various investigative matters
publicly addressing
16 matters resolved 24 additional
matters
conducted 110 voluntary witness
interviews
and reviewed over 420 000 pages of
documents
and you can see why i was excited
to serve with you chairman deutsch each
of these tasks was agreed to
by the chair and the ranking member of
the committee the committee
operates effectively because it's a
consensus driven
committee with decisions made jointly by
the chair and the ranking member
but as to representative greene the
current chair and ranking member have
not received a complaint and determined
whether the information meets the
requirements of the committee rules
conversation regarding representative
greene
this committee has not even had its
first organizing meeting for the 117th
congress
but yet the chair seeks to bring this
matter before
the house without proper committee
consideration in jurisdiction and
without due process
i believe it's worth noting that the
majority did not have to refer this
resolution to the ethics committee
the majority could have brought this
matter directly
to the floor through a privileged
question but instead it chose to violate
the one thing that's working in this
place the collegial bipartisan manner
by which the ethics committee could
operate has always operated with
massive major accomplishments and
success
the committee on ethics has not
exercised its jurisdiction
over statements made by a member
but the timing of the statements does
put them
outside the ethics committee's
jurisdiction
the nonpartisan professional staff of
the committee has provided and the chair
is aware that i intended to share
this opinion today that quote a review
of public committee reports will
indicate that the committee has not
asserted
jurisdiction over matters occurring
prior to service in congress
where the conduct was unrelated to a
campaign for the house and or
occupy or occurred prior to an
individual's candidacy for the house and
also quote
committee staff is not aware of any
instance in which the committee has
disciplined a member
for or initiate an investigation into
conduct that occurred prior to a
member's qualification as a candidate
for election to the house
or was unrelated to the member's
successful campaign to the house
nor is committee staff aware of any
incidents in which the committee has
disciplined a member
or initiated an investigation solely
into statements that a member made prior
to swearing in
that are not otherwise unlawful if the
ethics committee is to review its
jurisdiction over statements made by
members of congress
on both sides of the aisle before
they're sworn in then the matter could
come
before the committee in a way that
complies with committee rules and
preserves
the bipartisan collegiality intended
it should not come to the ethics
committee in this unprecedented manner
it's not the function of the majority
party to make this determination
unilaterally
it is unprecedented for the majority
party
to take action to remove a minority
member from his or her committee
assignments
for any reason again let me be clear
i'm not here defending representative
greene
i'm here to defend a process
with phenomenal members on both sides
led by incredible chairman
has worked for decades in this
institution
and if there is ever a time to pull this
country together
and to handle something and model
something
that works
here we are
i'm here to defend these processes the
functions of the majority of minority
parties house resolution 72 is
unprecedented
i agree with ranking member cole's
statement that history
has shown respect for the right of each
side of the aisle
to assign their own members to the
committees they chose
and to hold their members accountable
for their behavior
thank you mr chairman thank you for your
time today i yield back
um i thank the gentlewoman for her her
testimony
um and let me let me again
uh say for the record that um
it has not been the practice nor is it
expected
nor is it in the rules for the record
that um it has not been the practice
nor is it expected nor is it in the
rules
that to remove somebody from a committee
should be going through the ethics
committee
i mean i mean steve king who
you the republicans belatedly removed
because of his statements on
embracing white supremacist uh ideas
did not go to the ethics committee so i
recommended the other committee
i give you another example of
congressman jefferson
uh that was his remove from the
committee was not as a result
of the ethics committee so we have that
that's that's the precedent okay
um we're here today because
to be honest with you uh the republican
leadership hasn't
dealt with this and it's unclear whether
they're able to deal with it
based on internal political strife well
let me ask
um mr deutsche mississi a question here
um
is the ethics committee constituted i
mean
democratic members of the republican
party do we
even have it at this community as well
no
miss yeah mr chairman first of all uh
the answer
is no we don't have a full complement of
members because the um
republican members have not all been
named so we've not yet been constituted
um it's hard to argue i just want to if
i could since
since a lot of this was addressed to me
mr chairman i'd just like to clarify a
few things
um it it's hard to argue that this
should the
committee doesn't have jurisdiction but
this should nevertheless go before
the committee but we can talk
and i want to clear a few things up but
then i want to talk just for a second
about really the heart of the matter
article 1 section 5 of the constitution
that's the house with independent
authority
independent of the house ethics
committee to discipline any of its
members for disorderly behavior
for which the appropriate sanction may
include a limitation of any right
power privilege or immunity of that
member there is no doubt
based on the language of the
constitution that the house is well
within its right to impose this sanction
but i want to i want to just be
clear we wouldn't be here in
this position today and that's where i
started i'm sorry that we're here
i'm sorry ranking member olarsky that
this is the first occasion that we've
had
to be together in a formal way like this
but we wouldn't be here
if representative green had not been
seemingly
and it is all and and i i appreciate
your
and and the ranking members words about
how awful these
statements are these actions are but we
wouldn't be here if republican
leadership hadn't rewarded
representative greene
with seats on the budget committee
education and labor committee despite
her behavior despite
uh her actions we wouldn't be here if
later mccarthy
had been responsive to her actions
we wouldn't be here if leader mccarthy
had been responsive to
what i am quite confident in describing
as
the nation's collective outrage
at representative green's behavior i i
wonder if i can
mr chairman just submit for the the
record a letter from
uh sandy hook promise or mark barton and
uh
and nicole hockley mark barton was uh is
daniel's father daniel was killed at
sandy hook
nicole hockley dylan's mom and they say
in their letter
we have dedicated our lives since the
murder of our sons to stopping school
shootings and preventing more families
from feeling the devastating loss
we must endure every day representative
greene has fueled conspiracy theories
and supporters
that claim that the sandy hook shooting
and other violent murders of children
never happened
these vicious lies deny the deaths of
our murdered children
and bring death threats and constant
harassment to our doors
and our surviving children mr mr
chairman
this is this is not we can't hide behind
process
arguments which on their on the merits
aren't accurate anyway this is
about language and action that
attacks the memory of those who have
been
killed in in by gun violence it is
anti-semitic it is racist it
islamophobic
and to say that we should just simply
spend time thinking about whether
everything that we know that's been said
is offensive enough to to warrant action
uh is it's just it's not a
credible approach to this whole issue
let me just say one last thing
on this because you talked about the at
the ethics committee the role of the
ethics committee mr
of the house when this
new member after this whole litany
of words and actions and threats was
rewarded with membership
on these two committees that
has done damage to the integrity of the
house the constitution
gives us the right to take this action
it is appropriate for us to take this
action and sadly
uh it is necessary for us to take this
action
because no other action to respond to
this
has been taken by the leadership
mrolowski
you wanted to respond yeah
you have to unuse on you okay
thank you mr chairman i just wanted to
finish up the response to you
um just to remind you there were other
ways to get this to the floor
it's the majority that decided to assign
this to ethics then bypass it
bypass the committee and bring it to the
floor you guys could have brought it as
a privileged
question you could have brought it right
to the floor i'm not arguing
i'm not sitting here arguing about um
the merits of the case and
and what you're seeking to do i just
simply want to say
about an institution that's been working
because you guys chose this way
assigning it to the ethics committee and
then bypassing it
and bringing it right down we're going
to destroy
what kind of integrity the chairman's
been talking about
and even member to member trust
politically this could be a power grab
perceived by american people i think
it's a power grab
consolidation of power that's why i'm
concerned because you chose to do it
this way you had other options
but and and i have nothing but the
highest response my friend from indiana
who
we work together on a lot of issues i i
have to tell you
i'm a little baffled by your argument
just now
because what you're basically saying is
that yeah we could have gone a different
way
and had less of a process if we had gone
the route of the
uh privilege resolution uh you would not
have this opportunity
to present uh your uh your points of
view
uh like you're doing right now so i
don't i'm a little bit baffled by that
you had
earlier you know what we what are we
doing today
and uh and you know and what we're doing
and why we're here today
um we're here today because of what uh
the gentleman from georgia has said
what she has posted i mean it is clear
i mean it's on her social media i mean
a holocaust deniers that she has um
given them oxygen i mean it's it's
really
beyond the pale the gentleman from
florida talked about uh
the you know the the the the
outrageous claims regarding the
shootings in parkland and
uh and sandy hook but let me remind you
again
of her statements
endorsing violence uh
at the assassination of our of our
colleagues
and so look um we're doing our job here
because part of what we're doing here is
we're upholding
the integrity and the decency of this
institution
and you know you had to ask this is a
political process i'm
trying to figure that out because you
know
the gentleman from oklahoma said he
condemns
the statements uh you said that you
don't want to be affiliated with with
those statements
i've said it mr deutscher said it you're
going to hear others say it
so we're all at least here in agreement
that
um that this that this is beyond the
pale
so i don't unders you know the only
reason why we're here is because
my friends have decided not to do
anything
and i guess you could say you know oh
let's let's
check it you know put it in the in the
um uh
you know in the ethics committee which
it hasn't been constituted yet which
republicans haven't appointed their
members yet
you kick the can down the road and maybe
in a few weeks or maybe a few months
everybody will forget about it
but here's here's the thing and i'll
just i'll end with this and i'll yield
to
mr cole but
you know what i worry about is what does
it say
if we do nothing what does it say if we
just
you know put our hands up in the air and
say well
you know this is just
you know outrageous statements and we we
just you should move on to do something
else
i'll tell you what an awful message to
send to this country
uh during this very difficult time and
we just all
lived through a terrible episode on
january 6
when violence occurred in this chamber
and to have people
in our midst advocating for violence
advocating for assassinations
and to and to not respond to that
and i think what we're doing here quite
frankly is the minimum we should be
doing
i personally think she should resign i
think
i don't think she's fit to serve in this
institution
but this is the minimum like i said at
the end of my opening statement i would
like to think we could
have a bipartisan vote on this because i
think if we did boy that
that talk about bringing the country
together that would send a message
uh anyway i i appreciate um
uh both of the witnesses here i'm happy
to now yield to my good friend from
oklahoma mr cole
thank you very much mr chairman uh just
some housekeeping business first if i
may i asked unanimous
consent for to submit for the record of
statement
from mr biggs of arizona in support of
mr babin's amendment to
h resolution 72. uh without objection
thank you very much mr chairman just a a
quick couple of points
um let me ask you mr wolowski and
and then certainly would ask you as well
mr chairman
but when this was
referred to the ethics committee did you
expect
the ethics committee would actually take
it up
never and why is that my understanding
of being a member of the ethics
committee is this is outside of our
jurisdiction
and i guess when somebody says we're
going to refer this to the ethics
committee
then it's kind of like okay well there
you know we have to have a complaint
we have to go through the process that i
just went through here we have an
investigation
the chairman and i talk about it and you
know make a decision as the chairman of
who's not speaking make sure they press
their mute button so we can hear
miss wollowski clearly thank you
certainly mr chairman i'd give you a
chance to make the to
respond to that uh sure
uh thanks thanks mr cole i if
if they're i'm just i'm i'm really at a
loss
because if the argument is that this
never
would come before the ethics committee
and yet the at the same time
the argument is that this should have
gone to the ethics committee
then you're creating this loop which
means
only one thing that there would never
be accountability never be
accountability
and just if i may just mr ranking member
in april of 2018 a facebook commenter
asked our colleague
now do we get to hang them meaning h
o referring to barack obama and hillary
clinton twitch she responded
stage is being set players are being put
in place we must be patient
this must be done perfectly or liberal
judges will let them off
and then she created a petition to
impeach speaker pelosi
and said it's a crime punishable by
death is what treason is nancy pelosi is
guilty
of treason mr cole i could go on and on
but if the argument is that we need to
have a process
but then the conclusion is that that
process would provide no accountability
that is exactly why we're here that is
why we must
it's not with all due respect that's not
an argument i've made
uh i think uh i think process is
important but
uh you know we'll uh preserve and see
what happens on that
uh last uh last point uh
we're not recommending doing nothing
that's not
what i suggested that's not what anybody
has suggested
we do think we're on unusual ground in
applying the code of conduct to conduct
before somebody was here that doesn't
mean we shouldn't do that by the way
that doesn't mean that's not worth
thinking about
because i do think these remarks are
extraordinarily disturbing
and they are worthy of being considered
and all i'm saying is i would like some
process
to do that and again it seemed to me
that the ethics committee was the
appropriate place to do it
uh you have an excellent record as a
chairman
of bringing people together to make
difficult decisions
miss velorski has been a member of that
committee and has been part of that
process
that's the point i'm making i'm not uh
don't misunderstand what i'm saying
do defend the indefensible because i
think these comments are
indefensible i just think there's a
different and better way to proceed here
and that's the subject of my remarks so
i know my friend would understand that
but i just wanted to be clear for the
record
with that mr chairman i'll yield back
yeah thank you
uh very much and again i just i mean we
can
go down these rabbit holes of process
but when we have done this in the past
it has it has not been as a result of an
ethics committee
uh deliberation uh and so at this point
i'd like to yield to
uh the gentleman from california ms
torres
thank you mr chairman i've had the honor
of serving in congress for six years now
in that time i have developed wonderful
friendships
with democrats and republicans
for example every time representative
virginia foxx testifies before this
committee
i try to remind her how much i value
our friendship despite
our policy differences it is also
beneath me to not
apologize when i am wrong
that's because this is the people's
house
the american people expect us to work
together
to get along and try to address
the challenges they face every single
day
the american people our constituents
expect their leaders to be grounded in
basic facts and to have a
basic level of human decency
and while i hold most of my colleagues
in
great esteem sadly
there are exceptions to this expectation
we are here to vote on a resolution to
remove representative marjorie taylor
green
from her committee assignments due to
conduct
that is contrary contrary to
our house rules and the
inaction of republicans
i am confused as to how long
should we expect to wait for republicans
to take
action on something so deplorable
to quote senate minority
leader mitch mcconnell looney lies
and conspiracy theories are a cancer
i would go farther than that they are
dangerous
and a threat to our domestic security
anyone who conducts themselves in such a
manner should not
be legitimized by holding a platform
on committees of national importance
let me be clear anyone
who tarnishes the memory of the children
the children who died at sandy hook
by saying the massacre was staged
is not fit to serve on any
any house committee
anyone who chases a child
chases a child a survivor
of the parkland shooting for the mean
spirited purpose of harassing
intimidating and belittling them
belittling a child by
shouting at them in public and calling
them cowards
while videotaping the exchange does not
deserve
to craft policy on the committee that
determines
how to educate and keep our children
safe
think about that regrettably
the trauma caused by this mass shooting
a horrific event led
to the unfortunate suicide of two
survivors
colleagues i am a proud californian
and i take issue with anyone who
disrespects
californian lives lost by promoting hate
against our jewish friends and neighbors
claiming
that the wildfires were started by
jewish
space lasers
does not deserve to serve on a committee
that sets
our national funding levels
anyone who questioned the 9 11 attack
endorsed executions against our
colleagues
refer to the midterms as islamic
invasion
simply put is
bigoted conspiracy theories are what
incited a mob
of domestic terrorists to storm the
capital
and as a result of the attack the united
states capital has
changed blue lives have been lost
when murdered at the hands of the angry
mob
posting posting this sign
on your door is not justice it's an
embarrassment
this building is a historical place a
national treasure
where my constituents used to easily
visit
now it requires militarized security
and still when i walk the halls i do not
feel
safe words have consequences
we're going through a time of tragedy
more americans have died from the
coronavirus than during world war
ii we need to come together
it is time to hold members that so
bigoted theories that have caused
bloodshed
and that are meant to divide us
accountable for their words and actions
we must hold members of congress to a
standard
that reflects the historical dignity
of this body with that mr chairman
i yield back thank you very much mr
burgess
thank you mr chairman and uh
let me just associate myself remarks of
our ranking member
mr cole the sage of oklahoma um i think
he said things quite
well and quite succinctly i will say for
the record i don't support the comments
that are attributed
to our colleague from georgia to indeed
in full disclosure i
supported and worked for someone else in
that primary
uh at the same time i'm like
ms volorski i don't quite understand the
referral to the ethics committee but
perhaps that will be
further explained as as the hearing goes
on but
the interest of time i'm getting back
thank you very much go to mr raskin
right now
uh mr chairman can i pass for the moment
and come back to me i'm just completing
one other thing
is mr is mr perlmutter
no okay let me go to uh mr
russian taller thank you mr chairman i
appreciate it i'd like to
echo the sentiment of ranking member
cole
i would like to just uh draw attention
to the fact that
we do need to look at the precedent
setting for
a statute of limitations uh to my
knowledge when we've done this in the
past
it's been for comments that have been
made while the member was in office
i just think i'm not advocating one way
or the other
i'm just saying that the question needs
to be asked
are we going to adopt the statute of
limitations and if we are
how far back that statute limitation uh
it goes back additionally that would
lead to the question of
when does the ethics committee have
jurisdiction so for example
if comments are made in that such
limitations period
whenever it is when that person is a
candidate do they then get vetted by the
ethics committee these are just
questions
i am posing uh because if we are going
to go down this route the president is
set which would require
a a statutory limitation with that i
yield back thank you
i thank the gentleman very much i just
want to again point out that
the gentleman from georgia is double
down on her
uh comments uh she's been quite as as a
member of congress
as a member of congress and you can
check her twitter account out uh
to validate that i'm now healing to ms
scanlon
thank you mr chairman you know uh
listening to our witnesses and the
members of this committee all i can
think about is what a
terribly sad day this is for our country
and for congress
uh but we don't have a choice but to
deal with this historically the parties
have policed themselves
even as recently as a couple years ago
our republican colleagues removed a
member from committees
after he made a series of false and
despicable statements
but that was the old gop now when a
member of the house republican caucus
advocates for insurrection
violence against elected officials and
children or promotes fringe conspiracy
theories
a parent republican party embraces that
member and assigns her to committees
where her unhinged beliefs can do the
most harm
for apparently the party of limited
government and fiscal responsibility
free markets and peace through strength
has become the party of conspiracy
theories and q anon
and that's not my assessment that's a
direct quote from republican senator
john thune
of south dakota a republican party that
endorses
the violence and conspiracy theories
espoused by the representative from
georgia
is not our parents republican party it's
not ronald reagan's
gop or the bush's gop and if today's
house republican caucus wants to embrace
this behavior
the majority does not we cannot because
as the bill before us
states this member's behavior does not
reflect
credibly upon the house representative
green's extensive
detailed and public history of making
dangerous and downright outrageous
comments cannot go
unaddressed my colleagues on the other
side of the aisle know this
and by refusing to hold a member of
their own party accountable they force
us to take the unprecedented
but necessary action to stop the spread
of conspiracy theories lies and hate in
congress
um you know
representative green apparently stands
for the republican party that
likes to own the libs on twitter and
fire up the base with misinformation and
outright lies
particularly the big lie promoted by the
ex-president that his
loss of the presidential election was
tied to fraud
a blatantly untrue allegation that when
repeated
often enough and loudly enough incited
the violent attack on a joint session of
congress
in this building one month ago today
but that's how we got here to where we
are today years of
angry vengeful alt-right pundits sowing
racism
anti-semitism islamophobia and lies
about america so now they've infected
the grand old party and now republican
leadership
is doing nothing to separate themselves
or their constituents from these
conspiracy theories
that thrive against the hatred
no matter how much our colleagues today
say that they disapprove of the
representatives conduct they must
realize she's now the face of their
party
the woman who supported the armed
insurrection of the capital
which has taken the lives of six people
including three
police officers has more influence on
her party
than our colleagues here do today think
about this if marjorie taylor greene was
in
any other job she could not avoid
serious disciplinary action
with her history of advocating for
violence against her colleagues
challenging police officers and refusing
to abide by law enforcement rules
put in place for the security of
everyone who works in this building
and advocating for lies which undermine
the job we're all entrusted to do
here for the american people so this
conduct would not be tolerated in any
other workplace in america
and the capital should be no different
this isn't cancelling the voice of the
representative from georgia
it's about accountability as one of our
colleagues has mentioned there is no
right to committee assignments
but if a member conducts themselves in
so disgraceful a way that she brings
discredit among congress
and her own party is incapable of
addressing the problem
then the house as a whole has to do it
and with that i yield back
thank you very much
and and mr chair i appreciate the
opportunity and you know as one of the
freshmen members and new to congress you
know
it really does seem to me that this
would be setting a new precedent
and and one that i think could be very
dangerous it's a precedent where the
majority party
can punish a member of the minority
party by removing them
from their committee assignments and and
i really don't believe that this
president
is in the best interest of the body and
but i appreciate the opportunity to take
just a minute thank you
uh thank you very much um mr
mr perlmutter are you ready or mr askin
who's
um yes i'm delighted to go mr chair
okay um with your permission mr chairman
um
yeah i just want to speak in very strong
favor of this
resolution i was hoping uh when i first
saw it that this would be an opportunity
for real bipartisanship
on the part of the rules committee and
we love our colleagues on both sides of
the aisle in the committee and i thought
that we could model for the whole house
our determination to stand against
this kind of militant and deranged
extremism
which has become such a threat to
american democracy
i was delighted to see the remarks by uh
the senate republican leader mr
mcconnell who said
and on the quote loony lies and
conspiracy theories are
cancer for the republican party and our
country
somebody who suggested that perhaps no
airplane hit the pentagon on 911
that horrifying school shootings were
pre-staged
and that the clintons crashed john f
kennedy junior's airplane
is not living in reality this has
nothing to do with the challenges
facing american families or the robust
debates on substance
that can strengthen our party i've been
reading sid blumenthal's wonderful
multi-volume biography of abraham
lincoln which i recommend to my
colleagues because
it's about lincoln as a politician and
how he always tried to put
moral criteria at the center of
political
controversy so he would be anchored in a
moral analysis
and when he founded the
the gop it wasn't called the gop then
but when he founded the republican party
he was taking on the know-nothings and
he hated their racism
and he hated their conspiracy theories
and he hated their anti-immigrant
feeling which was directed then at the
irish unit the germans
that was the foundation of the
republican party one of our great
republican parties and i would
take no delight in seeing the republican
party
destroyed but it is being destroyed
by these fanatical conspiracy theories
and by the racism
and by the anti-semitism that has been
unleashed
by this kind of thinking and so um
you know if the if our friends in the
republican party
won't take a strong stand against it
then we in the house of representatives
must take a strong stand against it and
i favor this resolution and i yield back
to you mr chairman
hey thank you very much and let me let
me just say again
as i said in the beginning i hope that
uh when this comes to a vote that it's a
bipartisan vote
um because i think that would be a
strong unifying
message to this country and you know
i've heard a lot about president i mean
the new precedent here is that a member
of this house
uh is calling for assassinations that's
the that's the new precedent
and as i said you know uh
if that's the standard that we uh
we move people from committees
i'm fine with that i'm fine with that um
mr perlmutter
well thanks mr chair i came in uh late i
did hear miss fischbach and some of miss
willowski's comments ah this gives me no
pleasure and i agree with miss fishbach
this is the president i don't like this
precedent
but as the chairman has said the
language
screen has used the
the universe that she has lives in
denying the school shootings and
lasers from outer space starting the
fires
of tragedy more americans have died from
the coronavirus than during world war
ii we need to come together
it is time to hold members that so
bigoted theories that have caused
bloodshed
and that are meant to divide us
accountable for their words and actions
we must hold members of congress to a
standard
that reflects the historical dignity
of this body with that mr chairman
i yield back thank you very much mr
burgess
thank you mr chairman and uh
we just associate myself with the
remarks of our ranking member
mr cole the sage of oklahoma um i think
he said things quite
well and quite succinctly i will say for
the record i don't support the comments
that are attributed
to our colleague from georgia indeed in
full disclosure i
supported and worked for someone else in
that primary
at the same time i'm like mrs velarski i
don't
quite understand the referral to the
ethics committee but perhaps that will
be
further explained as as the hearing goes
on but in the interest of time i'm going
to give back
thank you very much i'm going to go to
mr raskin right now
mr chairman can i pass for the moment
and come back to me i'm just completing
one other thing
is mr is mr perlmutter
no okay let me go to uh mr
uh rashenthaler thank you mr chairman i
appreciate it
i'd like to echo the sentiment of
ranking member cole
i would like to just uh draw attention
to the fact that
we do need to look at the precedent
setting for
a statute of limitations to my knowledge
when we've done this in the past it's
been for comments that have been made
while the member was in office i just
think
i'm not advocating one way or the other
i'm just saying that
the question needs to be asked are we
going to adopt the statute of
limitations and if we are
how far back that statute limitation
uh it goes back additionally that would
lead to the question of
when does the ethics committee have
jurisdiction so for example
if comments are made in that such
limitations period
whenever it is when that person is a
candidate do they then get vetted by the
ethics committee these are just
questions
i am posing uh because if we are going
to go down this route the president is
set
which would require a statute of
limitation
with that i yield back thank you i thank
the gentleman very much i just want to
again point out that
the gentleman from georgia has doubled
down on her
comments uh she's been quite as as a
member of congress
as a member of congress um and you can
check her twitter account out uh
to validate that i'm now healing to ms
scanlon
thank you mr chairman you know uh
listening to our witnesses and the
members of this committee all i can
think about is what a
terribly sad day this is for our country
and for congress
uh but we don't have a choice but to
deal with this historically
the parties have policed themselves even
as recently as a couple years ago our
republican colleagues removed a member
from committees
after he made a series of false and
despicable statements
but that was the old gop now when a
member of the house republican caucus
advocates for insurrection
violence against elected officials and
children or promotes fringe conspiracy
theories
apparently the republican party embraces
that number and assigns her to
committees where her unhinged beliefs
can do the most harm
for apparently the party of limited
government and fiscal responsibility
free markets and peace through strength
has become the party of conspiracy
theories and q anon
and that's not my assessment that's a
direct quote from republican senator
john thune
of south dakota a republican party that
endorses the violence and conspiracy
theories
espoused by the representative from
georgia is not our parents
republican party it's not ronald
reagan's gop or the bush's gop
and if today's house republican caucus
wants to embrace this behavior
the majority does not we cannot because
as the bill before
us states this member's behavior does
not reflect
credibility upon the house
representative greene's extensive
detailed and public history of making
dangerous and downright outrageous
comments cannot go
unaddressed my colleagues on the other
side of the aisle know this
and by refusing to hold a member of
their own party accountable they force
us to take the unprecedented but
necessary action to stop the spread
of conspiracy theories lies and hate in
congress
um you know
representative green apparently stands
for the republican party that
likes to own the libs on twitter and
fire up the base with misinformation and
outright lies
particularly the big lie promoted by the
ex-president that his loss
of the presidential election was tied to
fraud a blatantly untrue allegation that
when repeated
often enough and loudly enough incited
the violent attack on a joint
session of congress in this building one
month ago today
but that's how we got here to where we
are today years of
angry vengeful alt-right pundits sowing
racism
anti-semitism islamophobia and lies
about america so now they've infected
the grand old party and now republican
leadership is doing nothing to
separate themselves or their
constituents from these conspiracy
theories
that thrive against the hatred
no matter how much our colleagues today
say that they disapprove of the
representative's conduct they must
realize she's now the face of their
party
the woman who supported the armed
insurrection of the capital
which has taken the lives of six people
including three
police officers has more influence on
her party
than our colleagues here do today think
about this if marjorie taylor greene was
in
any other job she could not avoid
serious disciplinary
action with her history of advocating
for violence against her colleagues
challenging police officers and refusing
to abide by law enforcement rules
put in place for the security of
everyone who works in this building
and advocating for lies which undermine
the job we're all entrusted to do
here for the american people so this
conduct would not be tolerated in any
other workplace in america
and the capital should be no different
this isn't cancelling the voice of the
representative from georgia it's about
accountability
as one of our colleagues has mentioned
there is no right to committee
assignments
but if a member conducts themselves in
so disgraceful a way that she brings
discredit among congress
and her own party is incapable of
addressing the problem
then the house as a whole has to do it
and with that i yield back
same she was appointed
to the education and labor committee
with all of that knowledge
that is a dereliction of duty
that is ignoring
the facts and the implications and in
fact
that is giving her yet another
platform
to not just hurt people with her words
but encourage other people to hurt
people with their actions
and i think um congressman testimony was
so
powerful about the families
of children who are being
further terrorized but the conference
gave her that platform that was an error
then minority leader mccarthy was given
another
opportunity to say you know
maybe that wasn't such a good idea even
with members of his
own party saying you know we
just don't want to deal with this this
is inappropriate
and it is wrong but no
he did not take the opportunity to do
the right
thing and that leaves us
it leaves us on this rules committee and
it leaves
us in congress to have to do
what we shouldn't have to do it should
be
up to the republican congress conference
to police its members to do the right
thing
and if you do not agree
with the way somebody is
inciting violence and and putting forth
blatantly false information
why why would you give them a further
platform
we have an obligation to do this for the
good of the country and for the good
of this congress and with that mr
chairman i yield them
thank you thank you very much for trying
mr desonia see whether we get this time
thank you mr chairman can you hear me i
can sense around
okay good thank you uh let me just
briefly say
uh i'd like to associate myself with the
comments of my friend from florida the
chairman of the ethics committee mr
deutsch
uh as a member of the education
committee and uh just
how implausible and remarkable
uh the thought of having someone who's
used this language
be on that committee um and then
secondarily just
if ever there were a time that we we
would
be aware of the importance of words
and their impact um seems like
it's a short memory it wasn't very long
ago so words matter words matter for
any elected official and i'm reminded of
the period when oliver wendell holmes
and justice brandeis were debating
uh first amendment or free speech first
amendment rights
when they said that you don't have a
right to stand up in the middle of a
crowded theater
in scream fire so too is the case here
you don't have a right as a member of
congress to use to weaponize this kind
of language
we've seen the clear and present danger
when people do this
in an era of social media and
unfortunately too many elected officials
thinking attention is what they're here
for
we have to at least as the chairman said
take this action
and as others have said i'm not i'm not
the least bit
happy that we have to be here but i'm
also
uh not the least bit um
doubting in the validity of the actions
that are proposed here today
and i would urge my colleagues to vote
uh
for this resolution thank you mr
chairman i yield back thank you i think
everybody's asked questions but i want
to give mr lewis
mr deutch the final word because you've
had you've heard a lot here so i want to
make sure if there's anything that
anybody missed or any last points you
want to make
give you the update i know you have to
go to another meeting but i want you
you can go ms velasquez
thanks again mr chairman i just want to
uh yeah
tell all of my colleagues are on this
call and i thank them for being on this
call
i just want to re-emphasize that i
really believe that taking this step
it does weaponize the ethics committee
and i think it's a tragedy that that's
exactly what's going to happen you know
there's comments from a lot of members
um you know we've made decisions in the
ethics committee before
that we're not looking prior to folks
being in congress and i think that we're
walking down this unprecedented path and
i just want to say it with
with a warning and with a disappointment
that we have a phenomenal committee
that's really a model but committee
should be when it comes to being
bipartisan
and working each other working these
things out in the committee process and
i think that we are weaponizing a
committee that will regret
and i think it's um i think it's sad i
just think it's wrong but i
i am grateful for the opportunity mr
chairman to be here as a witness
and thank you to all my colleagues for
your opinions as well and i yield back
mr deutsch
thank you mr chairman um i first want to
just also submit for the record
uh a letter from stan with parkland the
national association of families for
safe
schools founded by the families of the
victims in the parkland high school
massacre who
wrote respectfully requesting that uh
wrote to
uh leader mccarthy respectfully
requesting that representative green be
removed from the
educational labor committee i wanted mr
chairman just
to quickly make clear once again
it's been a long hearing but the
constitution clearly provides
the with the house best with the house
the independent authority
independent independent of the ethics
committee to discipline any of its
members
where the appropriate sanction may
include the limitation of any right
power privilege
or immunity of that member we are well
within our rights to do this
i would like to talk just i would like
to again uh
address the issue of precedent i mr
chairman you said this eloquently and i
i just couldn't agree more
the precedent that we should be
concerned with is the president of
the precedent of not allowing members
who traffic
in anti-semitism and racism and
islamophobia
and violent threats against public
officials to have the benefit of sitting
on a committee in the house of
representatives the precedent that
members of congress cannot trade in
conspiracy theories
without consequences and the president
that members should not and cannot
attack and harass
private citizens let alone survivors of
gun violence without consequences
mr chairman we've not had a chance to to
talk about uh but i would just refer
back to
just last congress from the house passed
almost unanimously
a resolution uh that condemned q anon
and the conspiracy theories that it
promotes that resolution conveyed the
sense
of the house of representatives of which
we are all apart
that conspiracy theories like those
promoted by tune on encourage the
rejection of objective reality
deepen our nation's political
polarization and
undermine trust in america's democratic
institutions
we cannot afford to allow that trust to
be undermined anymore
i i am i say this we talk about
our colleagues um i do view ranking
member wallarsky as a friend
i am sorry that this is the first
opportunity that we have to work
together in this capacity
and i and i mean this not as an attack
against her
but merely as a defense of the people
that i represent and so many around the
country
when i tell you that i know for a fact
with absolute certitude that
when we use a word like tragedy
to talk about the decision to simply
make sure that there is
accountability here that for the
families
in parkland and the families in sandy
hook
and the families in las vegas who know
that this is a person who has questioned
whether these mass shootings even
existed um
they know what tragedy is they've
experienced
tragedy they live it every single
day we have to act today mr chairman i
hope we do it in the bipartisan way
today
and again on thursday my colleagues all
seem in agreement
that what's been said is unacceptable is
unacceptable
so then we need to take this action
because it is the only
opportunity that we have to do so i
really appreciate the opportunity to be
with you
and i thank the committee for being so
thoughtful and deliberative throughout
this entire process
well i thank you both um for uh for
being here
um let me just wait does any other
committee wish to ask a question
seeing none let me just close by saying
i want to thank you both
for being here i have enormous for both
of you
um but i think what's frustrating to me
about this hearing
mr deutsch just referenced it is that
some of my friends on the republican
side
uh just begin by saying we are in
agreement that we're
appalled by these statements and then
it's followed by
a but uh but the process but the pri
well first of all as we've said over and
over and over again
the history of removing people from
committees
doesn't go by way of the ethics
committee number one
number two we're not weaponizing at this
committee the ethics committee is not
even constituted the republicans have
any
members on the ethics committee uh but i
would just
say this i really hope that uh
the leadership on the republican side
gives members
the freedom to vote their conscience
on this because this is not about
process
this is about who we are this is about
this institution
this is about decency i mean we
we are dealing with somebody who has
said things that go
beyond the pale i mean talking about
assassinating
members of congress among other things
so this is a whole different
place we're in and to be just very
candid here
this is not a surprise leader mccarthy
has been told
that this was becoming unless
he acted um it's february 3rd
uh we've waited long enough and
i think we are proceeding in a way that
quite frankly affords more of a process
than if this were brought to the floor
under a privileged resolution
so i again we all regret we are in this
moment
um but you know here we are and i think
the question is
are we going to do anything or not i
hope that in a bipartisan way the answer
is yes so i thank you both
and uh you are now excused um i want to
welcome our next witness the gentlewoman
from florida representative washington
schultz
was the author of this legislation i
want to
thank her for providing testimony today
any written materialists used to admit
documents mail.house.gov before the
conclusion of this hearing
will without objection be entered at the
record i now recognize the gentleman
from florida miss wasserman schultz
thank you chairman mcgovern ranking
member cole and members of the rules
committee
i truly wish i was not sitting here
today to present my resolution to remove
congresswoman marjorie taylor green from
her committee assignments
but i've listened to all of the
testimony and
the members comments throughout the the
breadth of this hearing and i have
enough experience as a legislator to
know that when you don't have
a leg to stand on you argue process
i'll note for the record that there
isn't any member
in on this committee on the other side
of the aisle that has argued
that marjorie taylor green shouldn't be
removed
from her committees you have not at all
addressed the issue of whether we should
remove her from her committee you have
only argued process
unprecedented action by a member of
congress which this
certainly is requires necessitates
an unprecedented response it doesn't
have to be this way
as has been noted throughout this
hearing the minority leader
has the opportunity to take action
himself in fact
the members of the republican conference
could
have enough strength to urge your
steering and policy committee to take
action
but you have not in the face of a global
pandemic and in the wake of a
devastating attack on our capital our
democracy
we're facing another unprecedented and
divisive moment which threatens this
patient and i want to look at the facts
i know they've been gone over but i
think it's important for us to review
them clearly
congresswoman marjorie taylor greene has
advocated for execution of leadership of
this house
of a former president of the united
states and other political adversaries
she's encouraged violence against law
enforcement and utterance no member can
condone or continue to stand by
we paid tribute to a slain capital
police officer this morning
and just yesterday two fbi agents were
tragically murdered in the course of
their duties
in my own congressional district not
satisfied with engaging in sedition she
has a well-documented record of making
repeated racist anti-semitic
and islamophobic comments she has spread
baseless and cruel conspiracy theories
even claiming
as has been noted that the horrific
shootings at standing hook elementary
and marjory stoneman douglas high school
were staged
she has personally herself stalked
and verbally assaulted a young survivor
of one of those tragedies and called him
a coward
as he was preparing to visit this
capital to plead for legislation
he was 18 years old at the time her
bizarre claims include blaming the 2018
campfire wildfire in california
on a jewish space laser and dabbling in
911 trutherism
congresswoman green's dangerous
commentary continues to endanger
threaten and inflict pain on a gamut of
vulnerable communities
and that includes the colleagues and
staff of the very house she serves in
who were just attacked last month by
among other trump loyalists
the q anon adherents she associated with
confronted with her statements and
actions in recent weeks
as a sitting member of this body since
she joined the congress
congresswoman green has expressed no
remorse none
worse she now stands by nearly all of
these statements saying just today
we know who they all are we owe them no
apologies
we will never back down she remains a
clear and present danger to our
democracy
congresswoman green's support for
violence pattern of stalking and
intimidation
continued an unending pattern of
appalling viciousness lies and racism
both before and after her election is
what helps fuel domestic terrorism
like we have all just witnessed up close
her statements
and actions bring shame on the entire
house of representatives
and have fomented divisions within
congress and the united states as a
whole
i filed this resolution to remove
congresswoman taylor green from her
committee assignments
both on the house education and labor
and the house budget committees
this has become necessary because the
house of representatives
is a collegial body one in which we
succeed when we can work together to
solve problems
even when we disagree this is not about
whether we find marjory taylor
taylor-green's speech offensive
the point here is that she has promoted
and advocated
violence she has herself stalked and
intimidated those with whom she
disagrees
in short she is harmful to others and
harmful to the house of representatives
in our ability to function normally
we need our elected leaders to rise to
the immense challenges we face as a
nation at a time
when we must solve them with facts
ethical behavior and respect
lies bigotry and conspiracy theories
cannot be sanctioned
instead of peddled in these hallowed
halls based on her actions and
statements and her belligerent refusal
to disagree with
him she should not be permitted to
participate in the important work of
house committees
reducing the future harm and disgrace
she can cause
in congress and to the people of this
nation by denying her a seat at
committee tables where fact-based
policies will be debated and crafted
is both a suitable punishment and a
necessary and proper restraint of her
influence the minority party should
protect our ability to do the people's
work
and to take a stand against what we all
agree is harmful
and bring shame on the house but if they
refuse
the house as a whole must step in facts
evidence
and moral thoughtful arguments will lead
to the valuable truths that make this
nation stronger
lies hate-filled conspiracy theories and
disinformation like those the
congresswoman green
propagates will always breed disorder
audrey taylor green
chose her destructive path she chose to
deliberately lie
and to comment violence and once elected
she chose to stand by those words and
actions and today
today she doubled down now that she's
made those choices
the house must choose to limit the harm
she can cause going forward in this body
we can take an important step toward
restoring integrity and truth in this
house by removing congresswoman
margarita green from our committee
assignments
while it is an action that we do not
take lightly it is the necessary course
of action in the face of her
extraordinary behavior
unbecoming of a member of congress thank
you for the opportunity to present it to
the rules
well first of all mr michelle's i want
to thank you for your for your testimony
and for your leadership on this
interview
um i have uh i have made my views on
on this matter pretty clear um so um
i will um i will withhold any further
comment at the moment but uh let me ask
my republican colleagues any questions
on the republican side
mr russia uh thank you mr chairman i
appreciate it um
no comments i would just say this there
has been talk about process and
republicans bringing a process uh this
this committee is
a process committee uh process is
actually
important because process is how we
protect the integrity of the institution
i've already brought up a statute
limitations issue
which which frankly needs to be
addressed if we go down this that route
again i'm not saying one way or the
other how we proceed
but if we do proceed we do need to
address a statutory limitations argument
uh jurisdiction issues with ethics
committee whether or not there's
issues with incoming candidates and
further
we also have to keep in mind that this
will set an issue where
the majority is selling the minority
who sits on committees you can argue
that is presidential or not
but there will come a time where the
gavel will change
um so process is important because it
protects
the sanctity of the institution and
stabilizes
the institution as we change from party
to party with that said i'll yield back
so i thank the gentleman for his
comments and uh yes this is a
rules really does deals a lot of process
and i think that what we're doing here
today is actually giving more process
to this issue than it would receive it
was a privileged
resolution um i'm not i don't know the
statute of limitations thing i don't
i don't get because as i pointed out
earlier
uh miss taylor green has doubled down
and made it clear that she won't uh
she has nothing uh to uh apologize for
uh period so i think she is uh
associated herself with those comments
well let me just say this if
the uh if if there's a change in
who's in charge here i hope there's not
but if there is and if there's a member
of this body
democrat or republican who advocates for
the assassination of other members
you know what i'll vote to expel
i will vote to get that person off the
committees as i said before i
personally believe uh that the gentleman
from georgia should resign
um or be expelled from this place uh
but at a minimum she had not to be on
the committees and so
if that's the standard that we're
setting here that's the precedent
the people are calling for the
assassination of other
members of this body and if that's a
disqualifier for serving a committee
i'm all for it i'm fine with it and i
can live with that and i think it's the
and it's the and boy that's the
that shouldn't even be controversial i
mean anybody on the
democratic side have any questions
i think we're i want to thank miss
washington michelle for her testimony um
and i will see her on the house floor
tomorrow
thank you thank you members um i now
want to welcome our next panel
representative
brian babin of texas i want to thank you
for submitting your testimony to
providing
testimony today um any written materials
you submit to the rule
to rules documents at mail.house.gov
before the conclusion of this hearing
will without objection be entered into
the record
i now recognize the gentleman from texas
mr bevin
thank you mr chairman i appreciate it
very much this opportunity
let me begin by telling the people
watching at home
a little bit about this rules committee
and what's going on here today
house republicans have 211 members 48.5
of the 435 seats in this august body
but on this committee which decides what
bills will come to the floor and what
amendments will come up for a vote
we have only four members to the
majority's nine
so the outcome of my amendment has
already been decided and was never in
doubt
it seems to be a show trial plain and
simple it's also an open secret that
this committee works at the direction of
the speaker of the house
that's an important distinction she is
not just the speaker of the democratic
caucus
to the committee i say this the action
that you are preparing to take will
shatter
our institutional norms and precedent
and there is certainly even concern on
your side
that what goes around will come around
the next time that you are in the
minority i think the best thing any of
you could do is to make a motion to
adjourn this hearing right now
and to get back to something that
actually matters but that won't happen
i'm aware but if you're going to take
this action and declare that each party
is no longer responsible for keeping
their
own house in order and that it falls
upon the entire body
to tend to this matter you should lead
by example
i'm not here to speak on mrs green's
behalf she deserves and will continue to
do so for her
constituents our republican conference
and to the american people
but i will say that this is her first
month on the job
she deserves the opportunity to do her
duties to let her employers
her constituents that is decide next
year
whether to hire her again clause 1 of
rule 23 of the rules of the house of
representatives provides
a member delegate resident commissioner
officer or employee of the house shall
behave at all times
in a manner that shall reflect credibly
on the house
this provision was also cited
specifically in house resolution
72 representative greene was not a
member of the house when she
said many if not all of the statements
that led to this course of action
however representative omar
has been sworn in for three months when
she said that the council on islamic
american relations was founded after
9 11 because they recognized that some
people
did something unquote there are two
glaring errors here
first care was founded in 1994.
secondly on 9 11 wasn't just
something that some people did something
it was the brutal murder of nearly 3
000 americans by 19 radical islamic
terrorists
and this very capital may have been the
next
target had four of those terrorists not
been thwarted by the heroes of united
flight
93. unfortunately i could go on with the
near constant litany of wildly offensive
anti-semitic america is a bad guy
rhetoric
that pre that representative omar has
espoused both before and during her time
in congress
the majority is seeking to hold
representative greene to the standards
of the house rules for her conduct
and words while she was a private
citizen but they have said nothing and
will
do nothing about representative omar's
conduct in words while
she's been in office i don't doubt that
many of you believe that you are
defending this
institution with this vote but now if
you can prove it
by going off the script this hearing is
supposed to follow by voting your
conscience to make my amendment in order
please take off your partisan blinders
hold your colleague to account for the
shameful conduct she has exhibited while
wearing one of these pins and then maybe
we can
talk about mrs green with that mr
chairman i will yield back
so i thank the gentleman for his uh his
testimony
um he is right this is the rules
committee
and the gentleman has been around since
what do you got he get elected we came
here in 2015 if i'm
not i did i came in in 2015. right
and uh so the gentleman knows that the
rules committee has to follow the rules
the gentleman provided an amendment to
the rules committee
i'm sure his staff must have checked
with the parliamentarian is not germaine
uh so we don't normally make non-germane
amendments
in order we never do uh so i put that i
point that out
for the record uh secondly um
and you know i don't really know the
gentleman but i would just say
um it is clear that we don't share the
same values um
and uh it is it is really um amazing to
me
uh that you would come before this
committee and present
uh what you just presented um and not at
all be
bothered by a single thing that uh
this taylor green has said including uh
advocating for the assassination of
members of this congress but
you are always welcome here even though
i
strongly disagree with what you were
saying here um let me ask you on the
republican side is there any questions
mr babin thank you
thank you mr chairman i appreciate it um
i would just like to thank my colleague
the good doctor from texas for coming
for coming to the committee
and to see if he would have anything to
add
thank you very much uh guy appreciate
you mr chairman
i would say that we probably do share
our values
however you can't wear blinders and see
one side of the table and not see the
other side
because that is not the only quote that
mrs omar has made
in her time in her tenure in congress
i've got a list here that i could go
down there 11 quotes
11 instances where she has made
anti-semitic tropes
and i i don't recall ever seeing
uh the rules committee institute of
proceeding against her
we haven't even seen anything said
against her by
by the speaker of the house she has
uh she has retracted partially some of
these but others she has doubled down on
and i could i could read these if you're
if you will indulge me
mr russian fellow has the time if he
wants to indulge you he can
i would um i i would just ask my
colleague uh from texas
um if we could if we could just move on
if you don't mind and we cannot uh
go through that i understand uh the
point you're trying to make but for the
uh just sake of moving this along i'd
ask you a brain about
that that is okay with you that's fine
with me absolutely thank you
thank you okay you're welcome thank you
anybody on the democratic side have a
question
um mr chairman mr torres uh
perhaps you can uh explain uh or define
what germaine means just to make sure
that
the general public who has been spoken
to
by our witness truly understand what
we're talking about here
so let me read from the rule jermaine is
no motion or proposition
on a subject different from that under
consideration shall be admitted under
color of amendments i mean that is the
title so
this is not um this is not real this is
not
germaine to the underlying bill and
again the parliamentarian would have
um i'm sure if it was if we if you
check with the parliamentarian would
have told you that but anyway the
stories any other questions
thank you mr chairman i just want to
make sure that all of our members
are um fully informed of what all these
terms are that are being thrown out
and i reel back
mr chair if i might pearl mudder
dr babin is a friend of mine and i am
that's right
disappointed in his testimony today and
i think
the thing that i'm concerned about i'd
say to my friend
is the republican conference uh
placed ms green on the labor and
education
committee knowing full well
that she doubts and has said
that the shootings in florida and
in connecticut and i don't know where
else
las vegas apparently we're all staged
but certainly at the schools in florida
and in connecticut that is
you know you've been in you you've run
an office i
was in leadership in my uh state
legislature in the state senate
never would we pick anybody i mean i
don't know that i've ever had anybody
like that but we certainly wouldn't put
her
put somebody like that on labor and
education
period and she has no business
i mean just that alone uh
sets up this whole thing and i
i've heard your testimony and you want
to try to equate to
rep uh omar with with what's going on
here
but this started by the selection of
miss green
who questions these shootings that we
all know it's
happened to put her on labor and
education
that is the whole point here
to my friend and i i don't uh
if you want to respond to that feel feel
free but
that's what's got me so upset period
well if i may respond mr chairman i i
consider
ed perlmutter a very very good friend uh
over the years that i've served with him
on
space and science we have similar loves
and likes and uh
we've traveled together and uh i really
appreciate that
uh and i appreciate what you're saying
and i'm not here
to address the
the supposed uh statements by mrs green
uh i have understood that
she has retracted uh some of these
statements
i am not versed up in them and so i'm
not here to talk about her
okay i'm here to make sure that what's
good for the goose
is good for the gander and when the when
when the chairman says that
i don't have the same he doesn't have
the same values or i don't have his same
values i can tell you that we
we probably most certainly have the same
values
but we cannot pick and choose uh one
side
that may be the opponent's side and not
look and see just like it says in the
bible if you have a speck in your eye
don't have don't criticize someone for
the speck in his eye if you've got a log
in yours
and we've got you have problems on your
side as well that have not been
addressed
and that is what this this uh this
amendment is all about so ed
i would uh i would just tell you that i
appreciate what you just said
and i understand the uh you know the
high feelings
on on both sides here so with that i'll
just yield back
mr chairman can i just jump in real fast
let me make sure that pearl motor is
centered yeah i'm sorry
i i'd yield to mr russian dollar
thank you mr perlmutter uh mr promoter
has said that
dr badman's friend dr batman said that
uh
mr promoter is his friend i want to say
for the record that i consider
mr perlmutter a friend but he'd be a
better friend if he invited me skiing at
some point
at his home state of colorado and with
that i would yield back
okay it's on the record ed
you got it i yield back on the chair any
other anyone else on the democratic side
looking for um recognition let me let me
just say
um mr bevin i that the false equivalence
that you have just presented to us to me
is unbelievable
um and the controversial remarks that
miss omar has made she's apologized for
um and um and she's actually engaged
jewish leaders in her community and
around the country um
and um you know the um and you're not
here picking
you you are here picking and choosing
because what you are you're a member
would do
is exonerate the screen i mean you're
you're this is not an and this is you
know you
you have you have exonerated her um
and um and the deal i'm not here to talk
about her mr chairman
well well you definitely this is what
this hearing is about um
i don't know if you got the notice but
that's what this hearing is about and
the bottom line is that um
uh you know you will come with a
resolution that essentially
exonerates her um and so i you know i i
look at i mean whatever
um appreciate your your being here i
don't um
i don't have anything else i want to add
does anyone
have anyone else have a question seeing
that i'd like to thank our witness for
his testimony you're now excused
um are there any other members who wish
to testify on hres
72
um seeing none um
this closes the hearing on hres72
uh at this time i'll entertain a motion
from the gentleman from
california mrs torres
mr chairman i moved the committee grant
hrs72 removing a certain member
from certain standing committees of the
house of representatives
a closed rule the rule provides one hour
of debate equally divided and controlled
by the chair and ranking minority member
of the committee on ethics
the rule waives all points of order
against consideration of the resolution
the rule provides that the resolution
shall be considered
as read
i am back thank you you've heard the
motion from the
general owner from california is there
any amendment or discussion
let me before we vote let me just say
one
one final thing um
as i said before um
none of us are happy about
gathering and having this hearing and
then having to report this
resolution out to the floor
we had hoped that the republican
leadership would have
dealt with this uh for whatever reason
they don't want to deal with it um and
uh and that's unfortunate
and so we are taking this step
we have a process in place that is more
of a process
than it would normally be uh
and um and we will bring this to the
floor we will debate it and we will
vote on it but again i'm going to say as
i said before
the question we all have to ask
ourselves is what is
what is the message what is the
consequence
of doing nothing and um
you know we've heard again all my
republican colleagues talk about
how they don't want to associate
themselves with the remarks of miss
taylor green
i appreciate that but it's not enough to
just distance yourself from her remarks
given the gravity
and the seriousness of what she has said
the real question is what action will
you take what we're doing here today is
saying
she does not have she should not enjoy
the privilege
of serving on committees that's what
this is about
uh anybody who advocates assassinations
of members of congress or anybody
anybody who said what she has said about
a whole range of things that we've heard
them here today
i don't believe i should enjoy the
privilege of being on a committee
and so now uh the vote is um the the uh
is there any other discussion or
amendment hearing none the question is
now on the motion
offered by the gentleman from california
all those in favor will say i
i oppose no no
the opinion the chair of the eyes have
it the motion is agreed to
uh accordingly i will manage this for
the majority
mr russian yes mr chairman it's going to
be mr cole
managing for us and mr cole manager for
the minority
i thank everybody for being here today
and without objection the committee is
adjourned
you